- I want to ask you, speaking of music.
So Allie, right?
Your daughter.
- Yes!
She's she's now doing the
whole music scene, right?
- She worships you too as
every female singer does.
- Oh, I remember meeting her.
- Yes.
And she was so lovely.
I think she was coming
from soccer practice
when I ran into her and I
was doing Trisha's thing.
- What are you laughing at?
- I think, I think it was.
No, I know, and I was like,
oh, we're like so similar.
Like things she said,
because I played soccer too.
But anyway, but I
remember meeting her and,
her whole thing was music.
So, now she's doing it.
- Yeah you two guys remind
me scarily of each other
because one, both of
you can sing anything,
but what kills me is neither one of you
seem to ever wear out.
- Oh.
- It's like two o'clock in the morning.
She's still, she's just still going.
- Oh.
- Wake up, she goes,
and you guys are just--
- Literally my makeup
artists just told me that
yesterday in the church,
she was like, I don't know
where you'd get all the energy.
I was like--
- Okay, so let's talk about
this if we can, right quick.
First of all, hats off.
Unbelievable job at the Billboard Awards.
- Oh!
- Now, come on, man.
You're sitting there.
You're sitting there
- You too!
with no crowd whatsoever
and you're giving 1000%.
- You did that!
- Well, I gotta tell you.
You know this in entertainment.
There's two parts of entertainment,
a great entrance and a great exit.
So, Cher, of all people,
- Yeah.
gives you the entrance,
but afterward that place is empty
except you come on and go,
yeah, that just happened!
Melt your face!
(Kelly laughing)
And you pushed the crowd button
and it was like, oh thank you.
Because you bookend it.
And you made me look a
lot better than I am.
But you made me look like--
- Oh, you shut your face!
- The Icon Award, it was good.
- I'm going to be real with you.
Whenever I got the script, I was like,
he doesn't have the Icon Award yet?
I was like, what were we waiting for?
- It's very (indistinct).
- That was kind of the crazy thing to me.
- I think there could
have been a hundred guys,
but Robert Deaton, thank God, was,
you know, directing.
- Yeah.
- And he's the guy called
me and I just said,
thank you for Country Music.
- But you did an amazing job.
- Thank you.
- There was no crowd there.
It was just the crew that
you were performing for.
- We brought our crowd with us.
We brought the 80,000 people.
We got the fans singing.
- That's so awesome.
- All this stuff.
It was so good. And man, again,
thanks for the opportunity because
what you don't realize,
these guys understand it.
You don't get to play anymore.
- Amen.
- You don't get to play more.
- I'm lucky.
- So any chance that you
get to sing and play,
thank you God.
Thank you people that do the Zoom stuff.
It's a chance to get to see.
- You're like me, the zoom stuff.
I'm not techy either.
(laughs)
- I love it.
- But do you know how to run it all?
I don't.
- No.
- Okay, me neither!
- I do know how to look in
there and go, I see those faces.
I see those faces at every live show,
you know, and you can
see them right there.
You can see the depth in them.
You can see their heart and soul.
- Oh!
- It's sweet.
- You know what?
- It is!
- And everyone gets touched
easily right now as well,
because we are like,
and now it's like, you
know, booming again.
Everything's in red and it's like, gosh,
everybody just wants to be around people.
And it's the hardest thing.
- You see this because
the sad thing is everyone
gets the same view.
So nobody knows exactly
who I'm talking to.
- In the lovely green.
- But it's the lady in green.
- Like an emerald.
- That sits there, that gets it.
It's like, oh my God, man,
how lucky we are to get
to be together this way.
But just think, it's like
pulling that arrow back.
The more you keep us apart.
- Oh my God.
It's going to be like Woodstock.
(laughing)
I swear to God, I'm
going to be in the front,
like, going woo!
I'm going to be so excited.
- It's going to be so good.
And there's going to be
800 artists like me and you
go get the hell out of my way,
because I want to get on that stage.
And I want to hear those voices.
- There's not going to be enough stages.
We're just going to start
playing like tailgate,
like parking lots.
- I tell you what, I'm sure
you got a million gigs,
but my stage is big enough for both of us.
- Oh my gosh!
- It's not big enough for your voice,
but we'll add on.
- No, I freaked out
when I got to come out and I sang
and it was with Trisha.
It was amazing, anyway.
- It was fun.
- It was, and I never
got to see those shows
when I was a kid.
So, it's insane because
for me playing big arenas,
I'm such a theater kid at heart,
or like a club girl at heart,
I love the intimacy of it.
So, it's not so easy for me
to bring it in and you do such a good job.
Annie Lennox does such
a good job of that too.
- She's a monster.
- It's like, y'all just bring it in.
Anyway, I was, I was really impressed.
- I love Annie.
- But since you're not touring,
what have you been doing?
- Whatever Ms. Yearwood tells me to.
(laughing)
So, the honeydew list, I swear to God,
I don't know.
It's like in the middle of the night,
she must add to it because
I'll wake up in the morning.
It's just like four
times longer than it was.
But you know, we're lucky
enough to be on a farm,
every blade of grass on that farm.
(laughing)
- It's manicured!
So it's, you know, you
just kinda keep going.
You kind of quarantine,
Miss Yearwood said she thinks
she was born for quarantine.
Because she loves getting on
the couch, drinking her coffee,
reading a book and she
can, she can isolate.
- Yeah.
- But I think she can isolate
because she's Trisha Yearwood.
What, I'd love to isolate
with Trisha Yearwood.
- I would too.
So, next quarantine invite me over.
But I hear so on your farm,
I saw you have a bruised finger.
Didn't you hurt yourself?
- Oh, yeah just about a month ago.
This thing happened, a
stupid thing, it's my fault.
I was tired.
But the knuckle's coming down,
just about time to get
the wedding ring back on.
So sorry, honey,
but it usually goes there,
but all I'm going to end
up doing is losing a nail.
And I got to tell you when it happened,
I just looked up at the sky, it was dark
because you know, we'd
worked way too long,
us loading the truck.
And I just took my right
hand and just said,
please just let me have him.
- Yeah.
- Just let me have him, please.
And they were pretty busted up.
- As a musician, that's
gotta be a little terrifying.
- It'd be okay if it was on this hand.
- Yeah, that's what I'm saying!
- This one.
- Yeah.
- And so, yeah.
So when we play today, I might
be doing this chord a lot.
- You're going to flip me off a lot?
Cool.
- So, I'm so sorry.
It's called the F chord.
- I'm here for the bird.
(laughing)
It's called the F chord?
It's called the F chord because
it hurts so bad to play,
but it's a chance to get to play, man.
I'm looking so forward to today.